- This could ruin the whole
red carpet experience for me.
(lively music)
- Hey everyone, this is
Christian Zamora here
at the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter red carpet event.
I have a box full of
Bertie Bott's jelly beans,
and we're gonna have the
talent who walks the carpet
use this wand to grab a flavored bean.
Between you and me,
they're all really bad.
Are you familiar with Bertie
Bott's jelly beans candy,
in the films?
- [Billy] Yeah.
- Are you gonna make me guess
their names or something?
- Hello new family.
They're basically jelly beans
with not so good flavors,
and some good flavors.
So we have a collection of both.
- So this is like roulette isn't it?
With beans basically.
- Oh, this is so perfect.
- Yes, we have a wand.
You're just gonna stick it in there,
and you're going to pick one up.
Here we go.
- Oh my god.
- You think it's booger?
- Of course.
- Should I try it?
- Yeah.
- Alright, going down.
- Going down.
- It looks citrus-y, but
I know it's not gonna be.
- Have I got one?
- I think that one might be rotten egg.
- No.
It's rotten egg.
- Lettuce with sugar?
And a little hint of happiness.
- Wingardium Leviosa.
- [Christian] Magical.
- Here we go.
- It tastes like if I were to eat
the latex Michael Myers mask.
- Let's talk about... okay.
(angelic ahh)
(groans)
- It's booger.
- [Ed] Oh no.
- Eww.
- A bacon-y, sausage-y
thing, yeah. (bell dings)
It's not great, it's not what I expected.
- It looks like frog or
something, doesn't it?
- It looks like frog.
- Don't do that.
- [Christian] Just kidding.
- Okay.
I'm very trusting.
- There it is, there's the aftertaste.
- Wait, ready.
Cheers, there we go.
- [Evanna] All you.
- You could do this.
- [Lydia] It looks like poo.
- Do it.
- [Christian] Ooh it's a red one!
- [Mother] Is it good or bad?
- You don't like it?
- I don't think she
likes earthworm flavor.
- Dirt? (bell dings)
- Yes! (makes dinging sounds)
You got dirt!
That's so exciting, how fun!
- Well that's better than poo.
- That's great.
- He loves soap.
Tom Felton loves soap.
Good to know.
Alright, thanks.
(squeaking hinge)